all right so the corporate media smear
campaign against Bernie Sanders has
begun
and it's not only disgusting but it's
pretty transparent as well just
yesterday we were talking about Bernie
has taken the lead in a key
gold-standard
Iowa poll the Des Moines Register poll
and here's how CNN spun it and here's
how MSNBC spun it and the smears are now
starting to ramp up and the big breaking
story from yesterday the first weekday
after Bernie did really well in that Des
Moines Register poll is that allegedly
Bernie told Elizabeth Warren in private
nearly two years ago that a woman can't
win the 2020 President presidential
election and Elizabeth Warren has now
sort of confirmed it and lo and behold
what a coincidence the story about this
conversation was broken by CNN yesterday
and CNN just happens to be hosting
tonight's Democratic presidential debate
this is one of those really important
stories to dissect because there are
actually two actually that there are
really three stories here and I'm not
seeing anybody talk about all of them so
let's do that
story number one is what we knew would
happen I mean as Bernie's viability as a
possible Democratic nominee became more
clear corporate media which is in league
with the establishment would do more and
more to smear Bernie Sanders it's
happening it happened within hours of me
going live with that story yesterday I
don't actually think we need to spend
that much time on that story today
because we just did a bunch about it
yesterday I think most of you understand
it we just happen to report that it
would be happening rather than reporting
about it after the fact I think we're
all on the same page as far as that
story goes story number two is whether
the assertion is true so let's discuss
that now what are the facts that are
being alleged here the claim is that
back in December of 2018 Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders who were
friends met at Elizabeth Warren's
apartment in Washington DC they knew
they'd likely be running against each
other
the end of the Democratic presidential
campaign they reportedly agreed let's be
civil with each other let's not attack
each other let's avoid hurting the
progressive movement great seems that
that part is the agreed-upon context of
this meeting as the story was told to
CNN by four sources that they cite who
I'll talk about soon Elizabeth Warren
reportedly said to Bernie I think I can
make a robust argument about the economy
I think if I run I can earn broad
support from Women Voters and Bernie
Sanders responded that he does not
believe a woman can win presumably he
meant in 2020 running against incumbent
Donald Trump so who are the sources CNN
cites for people to people Elizabeth
Warren spoke with directly after the
encounter two people that are familiar
with the meeting
that's what CNN says three of those four
sources said that Elizabeth Warren told
Bernie Sanders she disagrees with his
assessment that a woman could not win so
we were very quickly dealing with is the
report accurate Bernie Sanders denied
that the characterization of his
statement is accurate I think that's
important and I'll explain why when we
get to part three of this story and then
Elizabeth Warren put out a statement
yesterday saying that indeed this is
something Bernie Sanders said Elizabeth
Warren saying Bernie and I met for more
than two hours in December of 2018 to
discuss the 2020 election our past work
together and our shared goals beating
Donald Trump taking back our government
from the wealthy and well-connected and
building an economy that works for
everyone
among the topics that came up was what
would happen if Democrats nominated a
female candidate I thought a woman could
win he disagreed I have no interest in
discussing this private meeting any
further because Bernie and I have far
more in common than our differences on
punditry
I'm in this race to talk about how about
what's broken in the country and how to
fix it that's what I'm going to continue
to do I know Bernie's in the race for
the same reason we have been friends and
allies in this fight for a long time and
I have no doubt we will continue to work
together to defeat Donald Trump and put
our government on the side of the people
so again she says
we disagreed about whether a woman could
win which gets us to layer number three
which is the context here the story is
being framed as Bernie simply saying
women cannot be President do any of you
believe Bernie Sanders would say
something equivalent to a woman cannot
be President of the United States here
is Bernie a long time ago saying a woman
can be President of the United States
the real issue is not whether you're
black or white whether you're a woman or
a man in my view a woman could be
elected president of the United States
the real issue is whose side are you on
are you on the side of workers and poor
people or are you on the side of big
money and the corporation so aside from
whether the assertions about what was
said are true the real tragedy here is
that this is being portrayed as evidence
of Bernie's sexism or misogyny or
whatever and it simply is not that and
if there's a criticism of Elizabeth
Warren here and there is it's that she
in her statement alludes to the context
but doesn't straight-up say the context
is not a sexist context it's a
disagreement over whether in the
political environment in 2020 against
Donald Trump
a female Democratic candidate could be
President now Bernie could be wrong
about that Bernie Sanders might be of
the opinion that because of sexism in
the United States or because of how
Donald Trump has clouded norms when it
comes to how you're supposed to treat
women that Bernie believes in 2020
sexism would cause a woman to lose to
Donald Trump now you can say it's such a
broad statement it doesn't make sense
that any woman would lose if it's the
right woman women are so different it
makes no sense to say no woman could win
so you can say I disagree with what
Bernie said and it sounds like that's
what Elizabeth Warren said to him but to
say Bernie is sexist even if he said it
absent any context is ridiculous let me
give an example imagine that I said I
don't think a Jewish person can be
president in 2020 talking about Bernie
Sanders for example Bernie Sanders is a
Jewish man is that anti-semitic of
course
if I believe that because of anti-jewish
bias and anti-semitism and the rise of
white nationalism that a Jewish
candidate would be unable to win in 2020
that's not anti-semitic now if I say
Jews shouldn't be President or no Jew
could ever be President or Jew simply
should never run because of whatever
then worry have something to talk about
so if Bernie's analysis of the country
at the time as a woman couldn't win in
2020
that's not sexist now I happen to
disagree with Bernie I think many people
could defeat Donald Trump if they're the
right people they could be men they
could be women the implicit smear of
Bernie if he said this is where this
goes on the rail so at some point
Elizabeth Warren if she does believe
because remember in her statement she
says Bernie and I basically stand for
the same things we agree about what
needs to happen in this country he
thinks a woman can't win I think a woman
can win
she should actually clarify and say the
discussion was not a discussion that is
an adjudication of a woman in the role
of the presidency
it was a strategic opinion about given
the circumstances in the country whether
a woman could or couldn't win Elizabeth
Warren to do the right thing and clarify
that if that's what she believes because
she's playing coy she's confirming the
story that is being used to smear Bernie
alluding to context that is not a sexist
contest the context but not saying it so
if you're asking me should Elizabeth
Warren clarify that she absolutely
should when you see endless
conservatives say a woman shouldn't be
president right it's not an insane thing
to question could a woman win in 2020
the counterpoint of course is Hillary
got millions more votes than Trump in
2016 and were it not for 77,000 votes in
three states she would have won so I
just disagree with Bernie's analysis but
that's all it is
if Bernie said I don't think women
should run for president we are talking
about something very very different so
let's step back now okay consider what's
going on here weeks before the Iowa
caucus right after Bernie takes the lead
in Iowa takes a lead in California poll
out of the blue CNN just happened to
report an Elizabeth Warren just so
happens to recall this two-year old
conversation being couched as Bernie
being sexist which is completely
antithetical to everything Bernie
Sanders has fought for for the last 40
years so here's how it's going down
CNN published the story yesterday and
they they just so happen to be hosting
tonight's Democratic presidential debate
what a coincidence
every minute during tonight's debate
that is about this Bernie Warren thing
helps Joe Biden the prediction is when
this issue invariably comes up tonight
Elizabeth Warren will refer to Bernie as
her friend and say that they have a
similar vision for what needs to happen
in the u.s. Bernie Sanders will say of
course a woman can be President but
moderators will keep going until they
can generate something more salacious
after the debate the spin will be Bernie
and Warren getting very chippy there
while elder statesmen Biden was
presidential he was focused on policy
and of course Biden will be able to
focus on policy tonight because CNN
won't bog him down with questions based
on this article they wrote about Bernie
and Warren which will be used to justify
questions during the debate tonight so
Bernie has been set up for an unwinnable
situation in tonight's debate if he
tries to focus on the issues he'll be
accused of dodging the questions about
Elizabeth Warren and sexism if he
buckles down and refutes the attack and
says Elizabeth Warren should clarify the
context was a strategic one not a sexist
one he will be accused of being too mean
in defending himself and if he doesn't
strongly defend himself he'll be
criticized for not strongly defending
himself against the allegations I said a
couple of weeks ago this election is
going to be extra ugly and I was mostly
talking about the general it's quickly
getting that way in the primary this is
on day one where I said I'm not going to
participate in the smears that can only
serve to divide
the progressive movement and prop up an
establishment candidate like Joe Biden
this is what we were talking about this
is exactly what we were talking about so
Elizabeth Warren if she believes the
context was not a sexist one she
believes what Bernie says has been
saying for a long time that a woman
certainly can be President and that this
was a strategic discussion she should
clarify it because otherwise she is
actually participating in dividing the
movement and we should very clearly
state that absent context this really
doesn't tell us very much one way or the
other and in the end this helps Joe
Biden because remember if this hurts
Bernie imagine that this goes shockingly
well and it pulls three points of
support from Bernie Sanders and imagine
that Elizabeth Warren gets all three of
those points even though the polling
tells us she would really only get 1/3
of any support that is pulled away from
Bernie but imagine that this cost Bernie
three points and Warren gains three
points Biden still winning it still
doesn't help Elizabeth Warren take the
lead and that's why this props up the
establishment right now the leading
establishment candidate is Joe Biden
tell me where you disagree I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman follow me
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show